[Applause]
hi how are you
thank you so much wow we got people back
we got real people
real people thank you real people
mast and spaced and tested oh my god
but the robots wouldn't be safer but
thank you so much for doing this and
going through all that
and we're going to have a good show
we're going to be happy tonight because
the super bowl is sunday that's a big
thing in america super bowl weekend
the buccaneers versus the team somehow
still called the chiefs i
i how did they slide on that
poor washington team they don't even get
a name they're just the team you know
just like
[ __ ] it we're not even going near that
[ __ ] but the chiefs we're still okay
but uh this is gonna be a great game you
know tom brady versus patrick mahomes a
20
almost a 20-year age difference between
them
what we in hollywood call marriage
oh yeah
now of course this year's gonna be
different because of the pandemic
uh you know some fans say they're gonna
be they're going to watch listen to this
with blow-up dolls
and then in a tribute to tom brady
deflate them
oh i kid tom brady
and who am i kidding you know what it
came out today 25 percent of americans
say they're still going to go to a super
bowl party
and it's going to be very confusing this
year when someone says pass the corona
ask your doctor of getting in a room
with a bunch of drunk screaming is good
for you
but yeah cases are down though this is
good news you know uh 45
well let's uh
let's not go crazy they're down because
we're over the spike
from the holiday season when americans
just
of course didn't follow the rules and
[ __ ] up and met with each other so
that's why it's down but now we're
coming up on valentine's
day i tell you for once being a loser
with no love life is a good thing
so well what else is in the news oh yes
ex-government employee donald trump is
in the news
he's getting impeached for the second
time this is going
okay
how brave of you
but this was going on exactly at this
time last year right it's like an annual
event now it's like ground
it's like groundhog day except with a
weasel
yes we are
so you know a second impeachment it's so
anticlimactic you know no one's going to
be watching
lindsey graham said there's going to be
so few viewers not even getting his hair
done
lindsay but i tell you that the
republican party they are they're in
trouble they have a real identity crisis
which is
kind of encapsulated in these two women
now that they had
they were debating whether to censure
this week liz cheney
you know her right oh we say we love her
now
daughter of dick cheney okay and then
you know
all about marjorie taylor greene uh liz
jenny daughter tick cheney
marjorie taylor green who and you know
liz voted to impeach trump so they were
mad at her for that marjorie's the
anti-semite who of course
likes to make little death threats
against democrats for their execution
they had a five-hour meeting
about these two women and then the two
women spoke
guess which one got a standing ovation
oh i guess you can't okay well it was uh
it was the crazy one it was marjorie
tyler green
and the democrats today they stripped
margaret taylor green of all her
committee uh standings and
but you know she's
should we is it is it
but you know marjorie taylor green is
now one of the standard bearers of the
republican party she's one of their
faces it's like having marilyn manson
host the grammys
and so listen to this you know they do
have a leader there in the house kevin
mccarthy is the minority leader and uh
he he's he's so afraid to get near this
he said about madrid green he doesn't
even know what kewanon is
really is it not his job
to know things that are happening in
america what else doesn't he know
hey what's what's with all these people
wearing masks
but hey
but really a five-hour meeting they had
on this where they defended themselves
liz cheney laid out her strong
anti-terrorist credentials
and then marjorie taylor green laid out
her strong pro-terrorist credentials
so
but liz cheney did survive she is going
to still be the number three in the
house
but only after promising to never again
do the right thing
and my favorite part was when
marjorie taylor green who you know
believes in every conspiracy theory she
said
she thinks satan runs the government and
eliz said no my dad's retired
you